nous allons poursuivre nos auditions sur
le
PLFSS 2023 et nous entendons à présent
madame Isabelle sans Cerny et présidente
et Monsieur Nicolas Grivet directeur de
la Caisse nationale des allocations
familiales
je crois que c'est le premier audition
peut-être de voir notre commission
j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo qui sera
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat et disponible en vidéo à la
demande le pfss c'est marqué par un
important transfert de charge entre la
branche maladie et la branche famille ce
qui constitue l'une des principales
mesures et qui n'est pas sans soulever
quelques questions madame la Présidente
vous avez la parole
mesdames et messieurs bonjour
je souhaitais tout d'abord
vous dire donc le conseil
d'administration de la kinaf à examiner
lors de sa séance du 4 octobre dernier
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 et notre
conseil d'administration a émis un avis
négatif sur ce projet de loi
je vous transmettrai les déclarations et
position de chacune des
délégations mais je souhaitais quand
même réagir sur un certain nombre de
points tout d'abord vous dire que
nous nous félicitions de la nouvelle
procédure d'examen de ce de ce texte qui
permet une analyse complète et
approfondie du PLFSS et donc qui
on reconnaît ainsi l'apport de la
gouvernance de la branche famille pour
éclairer les travaux du Parlement je
voulais également
souligner le nombre de mesures contenu
mesure famille contenues dans ce PLFSS
notamment la revalorisation de 50% de
l'allocation de soutien familial dès
novembre 2022 également la réforme
attendue du complément de mode de garde
le CMG et l'extension des aides à la
garde d'enfants de 6 à 12 ans pour les
familles monoparentales alors une fois
que j'ai dit ça je vous laisse quand
même
revenir sur le CMG vous dire que le
conseil d'administration et dans
l'attente des textes rég commentaire
d'application de la mesure texte qui
permettront d'en mesurer l'impact réel
également sur l'extension des
[Musique]
à la garde d'enfants pour les 6-12 ans
pour les familles monoparentales
là aussi je souhaitais rappeler que les
besoins de conciliation vie familiale
vie professionnelle
était importante pour toutes les
familles et notamment pour les familles
bi-actives si nous voulons permettre de
réduire le temps partiel subite et
concrétiser notamment l'objectif d'un
retour à l'emploi ou de maintenir
les possibilités d'emploi
également
vous rappeler
dans la conciliation vie familiale vie
professionnelle l'importance à la fois
des dispositifs d'accueil individuel
mais également collectif et donc toute
l'importance de proposer des solutions
d'accueil périscolaire et extrascolaire
aux enfants de plus de 3 ans
vous le savez nous sommes en fin de
convention d'objectifs et de gestion et
dans cette convention d'objectif et de
gestion donc
2018-2022 au niveau des ALSH nous avons
eu
non seulement nous ne pouvions pas
créer de nouvelles
places en ALSH mais en plus nous avons
enfin en termes de financement et nous
n'avons que très peu revaloriser ces
la prestation à l donc c'est pour nous
un point d'attention concernant la
conciliation vie familiale vie
professionnelle vous dire comme ça a été
dit en
début enfin en introduction ça vous
étonnera pas que
l'ensemble des membres du conseil
d'administration on déploré très
vivement le transfert de à la branche
famille des indemnités journalières des
congés maternité post naissance
nous le
nous le disons d'autant plus que ce
transfert de charge pose des questions
quant à la capacité de la branche
famille à répondre aux attentes majeures
qui lui sont légitime adressées puisque
nous allons
avoir dans notre prochaine convention
d'objectif effet de gestion qui doit
être mise en œuvre à partir de 2023
un certain nombre de
[Musique]
grands de grands chantiers puisque nous
avons le service public de la petite
enfance la solidarité à la source nous
avons la déconjugalisation de
l'allocation adulte handicapé la
contribution à l'insertion des publics
fragiles la poursuite de la politique
d'intermédiation des
pensions alimentaires et j'en oublie
certainement donc nous sommes vraiment
très attentifs à savoir est-ce que nous
allons avoir finalement les moyens à la
fois humain financiers et informatique
en soutien à ces projets qui sont
tout à fait
intéressant et important que donc non
mais nous devons avoir les moyens pour
pour se faire d'autant plus que
je le rappelle vous le savez
nous avons été au rendez-vous de la
mobilisation nationale pendant la crise
sanitaire la branche famille
a fait preuve d'un grand volontarisme en
faveur des services aux familles nous
avons mis en oeuvre la réforme des aides
au logement et nous avons respecté les
restitutions d'emplois qui nous avaient
été assignés
c'est important de le de le dire de le
rappeler puisque
nous avons quand même été dans des
conditions
délicates pour la mise en œuvre de la
réforme des aides au logement
ça s'est fait au prix d'une perturbation
courte et durable de la qualité du
service rendu sur l'ensemble des
prestations et en respectant la
trajectoire des restitutions d'emplois
qui nous avait été assigné en début de
convention d'objectif et de gestion donc
en 2018
nous n'avons pas eu
la les gains de productivité qui avaient
été envisagées puisque nous avons eu un
décalage de la réforme des aides au
logement et que nous n'avons pas fait le
RSA et la prime d'activité avec les
revenus directement à la source donc
c'est important nous avons donc préempté
ces gains de productivité et ça nous met
toujours en grande difficulté et en
situation de fragilité donc je me
permets de
de vous le dire et d'autre part le
transfert
de
moyens de la branche famille vers la
branche maladie
il faut vraiment être attentif pour que
l'on puisse continuer à financer et à
déployer nos dispositifs en matière
d'accompagnement aussi bien en France
jeunesse mais aussi soutient la
parentalité et à l'animation de la vie
sociale nous avons très peur que
finalement tous les crédits soient
fléchés sur la petite enfance notamment
dans le cadre du service public
de la petite enfance et donc
nous sommes
inquiets que ce transfert finalement
Prée la négociation à venir
donc de la prochaine convention
d'objectifs et de gestion sachant que au
vu du démarrage extrêmement tardif des
des premières discussions
ça risque d'être décalé comme en 2018
plutôt
sur le deuxième trimestre
2023 reproduisant la dérive observée
lors de la précédente période
conventionnelle et donc
nous sommes
aussi en attente de
la façon dont nous allons pouvoir
fonctionner
en l'absence de convention d'objectifs
et de gestion sur c'est peut-être six
mois ou plus
2023 c'est important que nous trouvions
avec l'État les modalités de
fonctionnement permettant au CAF
d'assurer sereinement la continuité de
nos activités et d'éviter aussi une
année blanche
en termes de développement des services
aux familles qui bien évidemment
compromettrait d'emblée l'atteinte des
futurs objectifs donc c'est un point
là aussi que je me permets de
de poser devant vous aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas si le directeur général
souhaite compléter ce premier
propos et bien alors je vais passer la
parole à olivierno qui rapporte la
branche famille pour le plfs7 merci
madame la Présidente vous avez dans
votre exposé clairement posé tous les
tous les sujets et je crois
qu'effectivement il y a une forme de
paradoxe entre le montant de de
l'excédent de 2,9 milliards d'euros en
2021 et puis depuis longtemps depuis un
certain temps et ça a perdu et ça
continue ce paradoxe entre cet excédent
et les besoins de la société en matière
de de politique familiale ça fait une
transition avec ma collègue Frédéric
puissat nous sommes rapporteurs du PGL
réforme de l'assurance chômage mais on
voit bien que parmi les frais et les
freins à l'emploi sont aussi des frais
d'ailleurs les freins à l'emploi et il y
a la gare de d'en et ça revient toujours
toujours et là-dessus on se dit qu'il y
a encore beaucoup pas faire il y a aussi
la question même si certains peuvent
dire que c'est pas une question d'argent
mais de la natalité qui peut ne peut pas
nous nous préoccupe ne pas nous
préoccuper et donc voilà je dis il y a
qu'on le veuille ou non dans ce pays et
plus encore actuellement même s'il y a
des mesures mais il y a un manque
d'ambition en matière de politique
familiale et cet excédent est et et
révélateur de ce point de vue là alors
les indemnités journalières je crois que
vous y avez répondu comme souvent au
fond on crée un débat on
explique des choses on met au fond on
n'est pas clair parce que le déterminant
de ce choix politique c'est ce que
Jean-Marie en lorenberg et puis
aujourd'hui Elisabeth Doisneau appelle
la tuyauterie du PLFSS au fond soyons
clairs c'est ça d'ailleurs ce serait
plus simple de le de le dire comme ça et
d'annoncer clairement des choses plutôt
que de chercher des raisons qui n'en
sont pas et qui sont au fond qui
résultent d'équilibre financiers globaux
qu'on peut comprendre mais autant les
afficher et d'un manque d'ambition en
matière de politique familiale voilà ce
que je voulais dire en préalable en
comprenant par les parfaitement votre
votre avis négatif alors une question
plus précise et plus technique
concernant l'article 36 que vous l'avez
abordé déjà avec la réforme ambitieuse
du complément de libre choix du mode de
garde sur plusieurs aspects le premier
celui de du CMG emploi direct afin on en
a parlé d'ailleurs précédemment avec
l'audition du directeur de
l'URSSAF caisse nationale afin de mettre
fin à des restes à charge et des effets
de seuil la portée de la réforme
dépendra largement des textes
réglementaires qui vont détailler les
nouveaux barèmes ressort-il de vos
échanges avec la Direction de la
Sécurité sociale que l'adversé sera
différenciée selon que la oui emploi un
salarié pour une garde à domicile ou une
assistante maternelle et si oui dans
quelle mesure avez-vous des informations
sur ce sujet par ailleurs la réforme
prévoit de conserver un plafond de
rémunération horaire des assistantes
maternelles et de l'étendre aux salariés
pour la garde à domicile pouvez-vous
nous éclairer sur l'effet de cette
mesure enfin avez-vous déjà des idées
sur les impacts et puis disposez-vous de
donner plus fines que celle de l'étude
d'impact quant aux éventuels
déséquilibres de cette réforme et et
soyons clairs aux perdants et le coup
que cela pourrait représenter pour ces
familles et enfin vous êtes au cœur des
négociations de la prochaine convention
d'objectifs et de gestion et pouvez-vous
nous indiquer sont des perspectives si
elles se dessinent et quand aux
objectifs au montant à louer aux Front
national d'action sociale et enfin
pouvez-vous nous nous éclairer sur les
risques qu'emporterait une conclusion
tardive de cette convention d'objectif
et de gestion je vous remercie
je vous prie de m'excuser je resterai
peut-être pas jusqu'à la fin de votre
audition parce que j'ai une rendez-vous
chez le ministre combe à 12 heures et
donc voilà je devrais au même moment
j'ai un peu de temps mais je m'en excuse
par avance si si
madame la Présidente pour les
explications que que vous venez de
donner concernant le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
finalement toutes les responsabilités
qui sont les vôtres et qui finalement
deviennent de plus en plus importante je
voudrais vous parler d'un sujet qui
peut-être peut être pris dans dans cette
convention d'objectif et de gestion qui
est souvent l'objet d'une interpellation
que l'on reçoit en tant que
parlementaire et en quelque sorte il il
montre bien que on ne prévoit pas tout
dans notre société concernant je dirais
la protection de celles et ceux qui vont
comment assurer la garde des jeunes
enfants je parlais des assistantes
maternelles en fait on a souvent des
assistantes maternelles qui ne sont pas
payés par les parents employeurs et moi
j'aimerais que vraiment on s'intéresse à
ce sujet parce que ça des assistantes
maternelles en grande difficulté et dès
lors elles vont renoncer à ce métier et
donc ça fait autant de place que l'on
n'a pas pour justement satisfaire les
parents en réalité ce qui se passe c'est
que ces impayés dont elles sont victimes
viennent du fait que la CMG
le complément le CMG est versé aux
familles et que les familles pour
certaines ne le reversent pas mais même
quelquefois
organisent en quelque sorte cet état de
fait et donc
cette difficulté que rencontre certaines
assistantes maternelles et bien il faut
les entendre parce que vraiment c'est
quelque chose de compliqué elles peuvent
pas comment
elle ne renonce pas non plus comment ces
familles alors contrat c'est qu'en fait
ce qui se passe c'est que quand
l'astante maternelle demande aux parents
de verser ce qui leur doivent et bien
il pourrait dénoncer mais ils le font
pas c'est à dire qu'ils organisent comme
je le disais cette faculté qu'ils ont à
recevoir de l'argent de la CAF et à ne
pas payer finalement les instants de
maternelle donc
ça finalement ça finit toujours très
très mal puisque les estantes
maternelles soit elles renonce à leur
métier ou soit elles s'en vont dans des
procédures très très longues d'après ce
que ce qu'elle me dise et donc il
faudrait regarder ça avec précision mais
on peut pas laisser des professionnels
de la petite enfance dans ces conditions
là parce que c'est effectivement
difficile à gérer pour elle merci
Laurence Rossignol
merci madame la Présidente j'avais eu
l'occasion de le dire au ministre quand
il était là deux points de satisfaction
importante dans la branche famille cette
année avec la poursuite du CMG jusque à
l'âge de 12 ans et le doublement
l'augmentation de 50% la location de
soutien familial des mesures extrêmement
importantes et attendues pour par les
familles monoparentales et donc c'est
cette satisfaction de voir ces deux
mesures dans le budget de la branche
famille je voulais poser une question un
peu similaire à celle que vient de poser
Elisabeth Doisneau attiré votre
attention sur le fait que comme elle
j'entends parler plus fréquemment
qu'avant d'assistante maternelle non
payées par les familles ça a toujours
été une
hypothèse qui pouvait un aléa qui
pouvait se produire mon oreille me dit
que c'est en augmentation et donc je
voulais savoir si vous aviez continué de
travailler sur le tiers payant
à l'égard descendre maternelle Vous vous
rappelez sans doute vous vous rappelez
sans doute de la l'expérimentation qui
avait été menée dans la CAF de
Seine-Saint-Denis sur le tiers payant
aux asmates des en termes de gestion
c'est pas très simple j'en ai tout à
fait conscience pour autant ça me paraît
être relativement utile et de
retravailler là-dessus parce qu'on peut
pas laisser on peut pas laisser les
assistantes maternelle dans cette
difficulté la deuxième sujet c'est quel
regard vous portez
quel regard vous portez sur
les difficultés les mobilisations qu'il
y a en ce moment dans les personnels la
petite enfance parce que c'est quand
même chez vous à la CNAV que ce
c'est d'abord et ce qu'on dise et
politique d'accueil des moines de 3 ans
vous en êtes probablement
l'interlocuteur le plus important donc
où en est-on sur l'affaire du service
public de la petite enfance c'est ce que
vous y travaillez aussi et puis enfin je
j'avais aussi attiré l'attention du
ministre quand il était venu en audition
ici je suis assez préoccupée de voir que
depuis plusieurs années toutes les
ouvertures
place de crèches se font quasiment dans
des crèches privées à but lucratif
et cette dérive
sans vouloir inquiéter particulièrement
les parents mais cette dérive est très
préoccupante je crains une
waouh
je crains je crains une évolution type
EHPAD
donc voilà mais question donc comment
vous envisagez de corriger cette
évolution que je qualifie
alors Philippe mouillé que
le président merci madame la Présidente
pour votre présentation
dans vos propos vous évoquez les
nombreuses réformes que vous allez
devoir mettre en place et vous inquiétez
des des moyens humains financiers
informatiques disponibles moi j'aurais
focalisé sur un élément qui est bien
entendu la déconjugaison de la location
du handicapé nous attendons le décret
dans les dans les derniers jours qui
viennent face à votre inquiétude je vous
renvoie une moi-même une inquiétude sur
la capacité à faire puisque il y a à la
fois dans la loi des délais qui sont
fixés mais surtout un engagement des
ministres sur la capacité éventuelle de
pouvoir anticiper la date qui est
proposée et donc on sait très bien que
ça repose en grande partie à la fois sur
la rédaction du décret mais j'imagine
que par anticipation sur votre capacité
à le mettre en place donc c'est
clairement gérer un retour de vos
inquiétudes parce que nous les
partageons également donc je vais avoir
des précisions
c'est Michel meunier ensuite il y aura à
la maison et Catherine brocassia merci
merci à vous
madame la Présidente vous le dites de
manière feutrée et avec beaucoup de
tactes mais je pense que la situation
est très grave et très préoccupante pour
votre caisse d'abord pour les moyens en
eux-mêmes puisque est-ce que vous aurez
la possibilité en janvier prochain
de prendre des CDI par exemple puisque
vous n'en savez rien enfin la coche
finit fin décembre 2022 et vous n'avez
pas de visibilité donc
j'en veux pour preuve la situation
problématique mais bien bien maîtriser
de la Loire-Atlantique qui
ne sait pas et dans l'attente bien vous
imaginez compte tenu des charges qui
incombent sur d'autres politiques voilà
il va falloir faire face pour ce qui
concerne de l'accueil de la petite
enfance moi je suis comme mes collègues
[Musique]
là dedans c'est quoi ça sa place et
toute la place qu'on doit lui donner
quoi donc voilà c'est plus un soutien à
à vos actions et puis surtout
j'aurai l'occasion de le dire au
ministre gouvernement il nous faut
retrouver un cap parce que ce service
public de la petite enfance bon il était
annoncé dans les programmes
présidentiels mais concrètement c'est
quand ça commence quand et on commence
de quelle manière voilà merci Alain
Milon et merci Madame la présente
je vais vous demander d'excuser
l'impertinence de ma question mais si
j'ai bien compris le début de votre
intervention vous disiez que vous
n'étiez pas d'accord sur le fait de
prendre en charge les congés maternité
en poste naissance sans complication
médicale alors je voudrais savoir si
c'est une position philosophique ou
simplement une position comptable
merci Catherine brocassia
d'abord une remarque pour ma part je
suis un petit peu choqué que l'on
transfère la prise en charge de
l'accouchement alors dans l'exposé des
motifs on associe ça au congé paternité
alors pour enfin ouais
c'est quand même pas pour ma part le
même la même fonction et le même rôle
moi je voudrais le collègue ont déjà
posé pas mal de questions simplement
vous poser une question suite à un
rapport qui a été fait au Sénat mais sur
les autistes et bien ado dit vous aviez
utilisé à la CNAV
des cabinets d'audith je voudrais savoir
si vous avez pour 2023 des
vous allez continuer comme pour les
réforme des aPL à travailler avec des
audits et dans quel secteur merci
et pour terminer Frédéric puissant merci
de la Présidente je vais très rapide
d'abord saluer madame la Présidente
votre détermination qui fait qui fait
plaisir à entendre parfois j'ai bien
noté dans vos introductions dans votre
introduction peut-être parfois des
désorganisations du des injonctions
peut-être paradoxal c'est-à-dire que on
vous demande de faire un certain nombre
de choses et puis avec en parallèle des
engagements à tenir plus réannuel moi je
voulais revenir sur l'accès aux droits
et notamment sur les maisons France
service j'ai pu en visiter quelques-unes
on peut noter de 6 de là parfois des
problématiques de relais internes à la
CNAV vous avez parlé de de de
problématique d'organisation de
personnel est-ce que vous avez bien en
souci d'avoir des relais adaptés
spécifiques et qui puissent répondre à
des problématiques techniques de façon à
ce que nos concitoyens aient accès dans
ces établissements alors on peut en
penser ce qu'on veut mais en tout cas il
y en a pas mal ça m'aille le territoire
et je crois qu'on peut plutôt saluer
cette initiative
merci voilà beaucoup de questions madame
la Présidente je vous laisse répondre ou
Monsieur le Directeur selon les
questions que on va répondre à deux voix
je sais pas si vous voulez commencer et
puis je les ai
complètement merci Madame mesdames le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs ravi
d'être avec vous aujourd'hui
effectivement pas mal de questions qui
qui sont posées sur la situation dans
laquelle on est et les perspectives qui
sont les nôtres perspectives qui sont
nourris par des projets néanmoins très
très ambitieux et très structurant donc
il y a une dynamique collective et un
engagement vous traduisiez l'engagement
de la présidente et je veux traduire
l'engagement de le conseil
d'administration de manière générale et
des cafés les gouvernances et des
services dans les cafés dans des
situations complexes mobilisation toutes
les équipes la crise covid a été voilà
fait l'objet d'une mobilisation très
très forte évidemment pour être au
rendez-vous et puis surtout l'ensemble
des projets d'être présent et d'avoir la
meilleure qualité de service qui qui
soit rendue dans cette période donc
peut-être quelques mots
puis après je viendrai sur un certain
nombre de points et puis on mettra avec
Isabelle s'en servis mais sur le les
questions que vous posiez en termes de
présence territoriage j'ai commencé par
là et puis de moyens et de perspective
sur la convention d'objectif et de
gestion donc les caves sont voilà
présentes elles-mêmes sur les
territoires avec toujours le souci
d'être le plus même de répondre aux
sollicitations de nos concitoyens quel
que soit les cadeaux que ça soit
l'accueil physique que ça soit l'accueil
téléphonique les mails les rendez-vous
téléphoniques qui se sont beaucoup
développés dans le cadre de la crise et
effectivement un partenariat avec trois
services qui s'est développé et qui nous
permet d'avoir cette cette ancrage
territoriale plus fort et cet
articulation c'est pas le même métier
enfin service ils sont pas le même
niveau d'expertise et c'est normal mais
par contre en premier niveau de capacité
de réponse et de présence c'est très
utile et les cafés globalement je crois
très présentes sur l'accompagnement la
formation des personnels des Francs
services on est grosso modo avec le
ministère d'intérieur les services les
plus demandés dans les maisons seront
services et il y a de manière générale
et je l'ai constaté dans beaucoup de
caisse
également un lien assez étroit qui est
fait avec la maison service c'est une
capacité de répondre une capacité aussi
d'organiser des rendez-vous
téléphoniques ou des visios avec les
personnels les Francs services qui pour
les personnes qui en ont besoin
facilitent ce contact voilà après il est
certain et Madame s'en servir le disait
fort bien que dans une période très
forte charge et très fort pression sur
les délais très forts pression sur la
qualité de service ça se dégrade
globalement y compris dans le lien qu'on
peut avoir parfois avec les maisons
françaises ce qui renvoie aussi à la
capacité
de formation en continu aussi des
personnels en service qui parfois se
renouvelle parfois évoluent pourquoi ils
puissent au maximum avoir compté le
premier niveau de réponse et si c'est
pas possible d'organiser une prise de
rendez-vous ce qui va bien pour le
deuxième niveau de réponse Vous avez été
plusieurs à vous interroger sur les
capacités d'action dont nous
disposerions dans la prochaine
convention d'objectif de gestion donc
c'est un peu tôt pour répondre à cette
question parce que les négociations des
mains à peine et que comme le disait
Isabelle sera servi elles vont
probablement se prolonger bonjour à tous
se prolonger dans le cadre de la dans le
premier trimestre voir du premier
semestre de de l'année prochaine donc on
est on est encore un peu tôt pour
répondre à cette question il y a une
question spécifique qui a été posée et
que Isabelle sorcière mentionné qui est
ce qui se passe entre les deux comment
cet objectif et de gestion et vous le
faisiez état des incertitudes qui est
question qui sont les nôtres dans cette
période et le conseil d'administration
sont des faits largement le relais c'est
un sujet qu'on est en train de discuter
avec notre tutelle je veux pas qu'il y
ait pas d'inquiétude exagéré sur ce
sujet au sens où on va trouver des
solutions pour fonctionner ce qu'on
demande c'est que ces solutions soient
les plus souples possibles et plus
rapide possible et plus fluide possible
puisque
si on est sur une période de
probablement six mois pas loin de
d'intercoches disons c'est pas pareil
que si ces trois quatre semaines à
boucler et donc il faut que les caves
puissent avoir la capacité évidemment de
recruter mais de manière le plus souple
possible plus normal possible j'allais
dire puisque il y a des il y a des
effectifs qui peuvent évoluer des gens
qui partent à la retraite il y a des
gens qui peuvent aller vers d'autres
métiers il faut qu'on puisse les
remplacer le plus vite possible et le
mieux possible dans cette période parce
que c'est pas le moment vu les projets
qu'on agir venir et vu la charge qu'on a
actuellement de désarmer entre
guillemets la capacité de réponse des
cafs de manière générale sur sur ces
sujets
sur les sujets un peu globaux de portage
et puis voilà après sur les sujets plus
politiques publiques thématiques c'est
que je crois madame progresser là qui
s'interrogeait sur le sujet du soutien
de cabinet extérieur à l'appui d'un
certain nombre de projet de réforme
peut-être souligner
parce que vous avez signé signalé la
réforme des aides au logement qui était
de réforme structurantes lourdes
importante sur lesquelles on a été
appuyé notamment sur les sujets
informatiques de manière très forte
simplement un cabinet d'audit assez
connu qui était incité pas mal dans des
travaux et qui était cités notamment sur
cette réforme des aides au logement n'a
pas été missionné par la CNAV mais par
le mystère du logement sur ce dossier
donc c'est pas la cnaval qui avait
diligenté mais même si on a évidemment
travaillé et pour le coup il y a eu un
gros un gros travail au fond qui a
permis de mettre en oeuvre cette réforme
qui a été difficile mais qui a quand
même été mise en œuvre et ça un accident
industriel au sens où on a été abandonné
à tout arrêter mais ça a été réforme
exigeante compliquée on pourra revenir
dessus si vous le souhaitez sous des
sous-jacents de cette évolution de la
délivrance des prestations et la
connaissance des ressources des
personnes donc oui on va continuer à
avoir le retour expertise par contre on
a très peu recours expertise stratégique
on est beaucoup sur l'expertise
technologique informatique parce que
c'est vraiment sur ces sujets qu'on a
des besoins très importants de projets
très nombreux et un apport d'expertise
externe qu'on essaye dans une stratégie
que je voilà que je vous explique je
pense qui est la bonne qui est de ne pas
focaliser uniquement sur l'expertise
externe sur les nouveaux projets qui
incarnent l'avenir dans nos systèmes
d'information et l'expertise interne
puisqu'on a des équipes informatiques
très compétentes et très nourris qui
gérait les systèmes d'informations qui
sont plutôt en fin en milieu fin de
d'obsolescence programmer à interne et
que à un moment donné on a plus la
expertise externe donc l'idée c'est que
l'expertise interne se renforce en
permanence et soit appuyé ponctuellement
par externes mais pas qu'elle se divise
des vitalisent notre expressive interne
là-dessus et c'est vraiment une
stratégie qu'on porte très très
fortement mais je distingue vraiment
cette logique très informatique dans
notre recours à
l'expertise externe et pas tellement sur
des conseils stratégiques de manière
générale même si on peut avoir ici ou la
beauté des besoins sur des projets
ponctuels
voilà pour je crois la plupart des
sujets un peu généraux que vous avez
abordés un peu plus de moyens et de
gestion peut-être quelques mots sur les
sujets plus politiques publiques que
vous avez abordés puis ils appellent
s'en servir évidemment donnera son son
point de vue mais je pense qu'on est
très convergence sur sur ces sujets vous
avez été plusieurs et c'est normal à
parler du sujet petit enfance qui sont
des sujets très structurants très
on va dire mobilisateur pour nous sur
laquelle la broche à mi est très active
et c'est Madame aussi la signaler sur le
rôle financeur très important de ce
dispositif pour autant on n'est pas les
seuls acteurs de ce sujet et notamment
sur les sujets de qualité
et de contrôle de la qualité dans les
dans les équipements vous avez parlé
d'inquiétude que vous pouvez avoir sur
le développement de certains secteurs
d'activités les crèches privées jouent
un rôle très important dans le
dispositif l'important c'est que elle
soit dans le dans la biologie globale de
qualité d'un service qui est qui est
dessus et d'articulation de contrôle de
ses qualités qu'on peut avoir avec les
moyens de la PMI dans les départements
qui sont actifs sur ces sujets
ce qui nous importe également c'est que
cette logique de développement
elle soit équilibrée comme vous le
soulignez on a une dynamique de
développement des différentes modes de
garde qui est variable sur les secteurs
et sur lesquels on voit dans la période
récente de la convention d'objectif et
de gestion qu'on n'a jamais interrompu
cette dynamique de création de classe
mais elle s'est ralentie notamment dans
le secteur public et ce qui renvoie
aussi à la capacité des acteurs locaux
en premier lieu d'accompagner cette
dynamique et donc c'est un sujet
d'inquiétude pour nous et de souhait de
notre part d'être en capacité
d'accompagner ces secteurs notamment
dans les territoires prioritaires
puisque un des travers de développement
que vous évoquez c'est que l'offre
privée ne se développe pas de manière
harmonieuse selon les territoires non
plus et donc il y a aussi cette logique
de présence territoriale
oui bien sûr bien sûr bien
vous avez tout à fait raison
non mais par contre il peut avoir tout à
fait par contre il peut avoir les mêmes
difficultés dans le secteur public à
financer et à trouver les modes
économiques d'équilibre de son action et
donc pour nous dans la logique du
service public de la petite enfance qui
malgré tout une réforme et en tout cas
dans ses intentions qui je trouve
intéressantes dans sa philosophie
d'ensemble même si elle devra être
largement précisée bien évidemment il y
a bien cette logique d'égalité d'accès
un service public donc d'égalité par la
présence territoriale mais d'égalité
aussi par les modes financiers d'où la
réforme du complément boîte de garde sur
lequel je vais revenir qui est bien dans
cette logique d'égaliser et de
d'harmoniser les restes à charge des
différentes familles puisque aujourd'hui
vous avez une différence selon le mode
de garde et selon le niveau de revenus
des familles vous avez grosso modo pour
simplifier les familles les plus aisées
ont un reste à charge plutôt équivalent
selon le mode de garde qui est choisi
les familles les plus défavorisées ont
quelques modes de garde qui leur sont
impossibles à l'accès au vu des restes à
charge qui sont les leurs d'où l'intérêt
de cette réforme très structurante et
très nécessaire donc qui participent de
cette égalité d'accès dans le service
public vous avez un enjeu d'in sur
l'accès aux services publics on sait que
les familles parfois ont besoin de
conseils d'aide pour se repérer dans cet
accès au service public et puis vous
avez un enjeu de qualité du service
public qui renvoie au point de vigilance
que vous que vous posez le un des points
de les niveaux d'ambition sera mesuré
sera mesura aussi au moyen d'en pouvoir
disposer dans le cadre de la convention
d'objectif de gestion sur ces sujets
donc rendez-vous dans quelques mois pour
en juger ce qui est certain c'est que
quel que soit ses moyens le sujet de la
pénurie des personnels dans ce secteur
est un sujet de d'attitude particulier
et de vigilance particulière qui renvoie
à plein de choses différentes dans un
marché du travail dans vos loyers malgré
tout des éléments de dynamique et donc
du coup de concurrence entre entre
secteur aussi ce qui renvoie à la levée
vous parliez de rôle de ce service
public de la petite enfance pour levier
les freins retour à l'emploi mais ça
s'applique aussi quelque part à des
personnes qui peuvent travailler dans ce
secteur et donc ils peuvent aussi
bénéficier de ce développement pour
travailler dans
et ce qui renvoie aussi à l'attractivité
de ces métiers que ce soit la qualité
des métiers et que ça soit les sujets de
rémunération peut-être souligné
simplement que dans ce contexte nous
avons été amenés à décider conseil
d'administration a décidé de relever
très significativement les financements
des modes d'accueil des jeunes enfants
et des crèches en particulier cette
année avec une augmentation de 5 points
au final puisqu'il y a deux de tranches
d'augmentation de de la prestation
sociale unique sur sur les crèches qui
doit accompagner ce mouvement
d'évolution des salaires pour être
attractif sur le secteur donc on est il
y a quand même dynamique qui est
présente en la matière pour
contribuer à combler ce qu'on a estimé
après enquête dans le secteur 10000
places vous citiez les chiffres sur
Nantes mais 10000 places au niveau
national qu'on estime ne pas pouvoir
ouvrir à cause de du pénurie de
personnel ce qui est significatif au
regard des besoins qui sont qui sont les
nôtres
voilà sur sur ce sujet petit enfance
pour ce qui me concerne mais Isabelle
chancellerie pour compléter simplement
juste sur le l'aspect CMG pour répondre
à Monsieur Hainaut on a effectivement un
certain but de travaux qui sont en cours
qui sont pas finalisés donc il y a un
certain paramètre qui sur lesquels il
est encore un peu tôt pour répondre à
votre question simplement
exprimé ce qui ressort de la volonté de
cette réforme
effectivement de légaliser les restes à
charge pour les différentes familles
selon les modes de garde et pour les
situations de perdants qui seront quand
même minoritaires dans cette dans cette
affaire de d'être attentif notamment en
situation de famille les plus les plus
fragiles le cas échéant en fonction du
taux de recours et l'intensité de
recours actuel au CMG mais ça fait
partie des paramètres qui seront
travaillés dans le cadre du des textes
réglementaires sur le sujet des
assistantes maternelles je qui tourne
autour de cette thématique là mais du
non-paiement des assistantes maternelles
on est également alerté de manière
générale sur sur ce sujet qui j'ai pas
le l'antériorité de mesure de
l'augmentation de l'intensité qui
probablement un peu plus forte que
qu'avant effectivement même s'il faut
pas non plus comment dire considérer que
c'est généralisé évidemment mais dès
qu'il y a des cas il faut être en mesure
de les traiter donc c'est effectivement
un sujet qui doit faire l'objet de
préoccupation et de d'accompagnement
national et local ce qui nous semble
c'est que on a un certain nombre
d'outils qui ont été développés ces
dernières années en lien avec l'URSSAF
caisse nationale que vous voyez tout à
l'heure avec notamment le service
Pajemploi plus qui est une capacité
d'intermédiation sur l'espace salarial
puisque les familles déclarent et c'est
finalement la sécurité sociale dans son
ensemble qui trouve le qui finance et
rémunère directement la personne pour la
garde à domicile et donc c'est quelque
chose qui nous paraît intéressant à
traiter dans le cadre de la réforme du
CMG pour aller vers cette perspective de
logique de page emploi plus également
plus plus diffusé pour les familles et
les
personnel qui qui le souhaitent dans le
rockeur dans cette logique là qu'on doit
pouvoir travailler au-delà de la
résolution des cas pratiques
individuelles qui doivent évidemment
trouver leur solution puisque c'est
quelque chose de tout à fait
inadmissible que les personnes ne
puissent pas être rémunérés pour un
travail qui est fourni et donc il y a
des et à la fois la situation d'urgence
de trouver des solutions pour ces cas la
situation un peu plus structurelle qui
nous paraît plutôt prometteuse par cette
voie-là d'intermédiation qui a déjà été
ouverte et qui peut être prolongé le cas
échéant dans des travaux prochains et
puis je crois que c'est Madame rossignol
qui évoquait le la mobilisation des
personnels du secteur de la petite
enfance pour dire qu'on est évidemment
très attentif à ce sujet dans ce
contexte global ce que j'ai perçu c'est
que ça renvoie aussi un certain nombre
de textes réglementaires qui pour le
coup relève pas de notre intervention
sur les règles d'accueil les diplômes
requis le taux d'encadrement un certain
nombre de choses comme ça que sur
lesquelles on a évidemment partie
prenante mais c'est plutôt un sujet qui
relève du ministère dans sa définition
des règles du qualitative
[Musique]
identifié pour d'autres pour d'autres
aides et ça paraît simple comme ça mais
c'est pas si simple pour la philosophie
d'un système d'information est basé sur
un dispositif familialisé conjugué donc
il y a cette première aspect de travail
et puis un aspect encore un peu plus
complexe qui est celui de la gestion des
perdants mais vous le savez parfaitement
et le décret porte sur cette question
sur comment on accompagne les familles
les situations voilà qui généreraient
les perdants dans cette réforme qui
seront plus plutôt les familles les plus
défavorisées du du spectre de
bénéficiaires de la hache donc là aussi
il faut pas se rater sur cette réforme
là on a un décret qui est pas encore on
travaille de manière active donc on
n'est pas d'inquiétude majeur mais qui
voilà doit être finement travaillé parce
que là aussi il faut pas rater des cas
de figure ça serait dommage de se rater
là-dessus et donc on aura une visibilité
plus forte qu'on se décrire sera sorti
mais pour l'instant on est déterminé et
optimiste sur la capacité de mener cette
réforme plus incertain sur la capacité
de la pensée beaucoup dans le temps on
regarde du travail très conséquent qui a
réalisé voilà ce que je peux dire sur
sur ce sujet
qu'elle était le premier à poser
question on doit partir si vous pouvez
congeler des réponses
bon ben c'est bon
oui ok très bien merci merci alors
beaucoup de choses ont été dites
peut-être
préciser sur les moyens puisque il y a
eu plusieurs questions par rapport à
cela aujourd'hui comme je l'ai dit nous
sommes en difficulté puisque nous avons
eu des rendus d'effectifs qui étaient
supérieurs aux charges donc de façon
très claire nous avons des stocks de
dossiers qui sont au plus haut depuis 10
ans donc
c'est
délicat dans cette situation je vais le
dire comme ça puisque début 2023 nous
n'aurons pas
d'effectifs en plus aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas de de signal dans ce sens et
nous ne pourrons pas non plus mais
il y a des discussions en cours sur
cette période
intermédiaire pour voir
sur des personnes qui quittent leur
poste pouvoir les remplacer si il n'y a
pas d'accord sur cette période
transitoire nous ne pouvons pas faire
dans l'eau donc ça c'est c'est
clairement un souci mais il y a le
transitoire mais je me permets quand
même
d'insister sur le fait que nous avons
une extension de l'intermédiation des
pensions alimentaires au 1er janvier
qui demande d'obtenir des effectifs pour
cette extension aujourd'hui nous ne les
avons pas donc c'est encore autre chose
que cette période intermédiaire je me
permets d'insister puisque nous sommes
en octobre
mise en place 1er janvier il faut le
temps de recruter une fois que nous
aurons l'autorisation et de former donc
en plus des difficultés que nous avons
déjà donc c'est c'est vrai que
il faut pas se contenter entre
guillemets d'avoir des autorisations
financières il faut aussi que nous ayons
les autorisations d'embauche qui est
deux choses différentes au niveau du
des autorisations
vous dire par rapport
aux difficultés peut-être
informatique
aujourd'hui les équipes bien évidemment
travaillent pour mettre en place ce qui
est demandé ce qui est ce qui sera dans
la feuille de route telle que
nous la lisons même si nous n'avons pas
encore notre convention d'objectif et de
gestion moi simplement de façon très
directe
je me permets d'attirer votre attention
sur le fait que bien évidemment nous
mettrons tout en oeuvre pour réaliser
ces réformes mais il faut vraiment tenir
compte un du besoin d'expérimentation
que nous avons pour éviter toute
difficulté et de sur des temps qui sont
indispensables de tests
nous avons si nous allons par exemple
sur la solidarité à la source nous
parlons probablement de RSA prime
d'activité lorsque nous parlons du RSA
on ne peut pas se permettre de mettre en
difficulté des
des familles donc il faut que les choses
et puis être testés et c'est pour ça
aussi que
nous n'exagérons pas lorsque nous
demandons en fait
un délai ou que nous nous annonçons un
délai mais que c'est vraiment déjà tiré
donc
je ne suis pas sûr qu'on puisse faire
mieux que ce qui a été annoncé ce qui
était déjà pas le délai demandé
initialement
sur les
sur les le service public de la petite
enfance
là aujourd'hui nous attendons aussi de
savoir ce qui va nous être demandé
lorsque l'on pense service public de la
petite enfance
on peut imaginer qu'il y a le même reste
à charge pour l'ensemble enfin pour pour
les familles que ce soit en individuel
et en collectif c'est ce qui est prévu
avec la mesure CMG
si on en croit les textes donc après il
faut regarder la partie des perdants
reste la difficulté des
crèches qui ne sont pas en PSU puisque
les crèches en PSU bien les les montants
enfin de les restes à charge des
familles sont encadrées il y a aussi et
vraiment je tiens à le souligner depuis
2018 nous avons créé un certain nombre
de bonus pour favoriser finalement
l'accueil
d'enfants en situation de de handicap
pour
l'accueil d'enfants de famille précaires
nous avons aussi
souhaité renforcer en fait les crèches
en
qpv c'est des choses que l'on peut faire
ou des crèches en horaire atypiques ou
des crèches à VIP tout ça c'est possible
parce que finalement nous avons mis en
place des des financements
complémentaires mais par rapport à la
PSU se pose
la question des
microcèches pages dans ce dispositif
nous aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
d'éléments par rapport par rapport à
cela
sur la qualité
il y a quand même un certain nombre de
normes qui ont été
[Musique]
généralisés donc
ça c'est plutôt
important pour pouvoir
garantir sur l'ensemble des structures
un certain nombre de normes maintenant
les PMI sont là aussi pour vérifier un
certain nombre de choses et on sait que
il n'y a pas suffisamment de
professionnels dans les PMI ce qui est
aussi un peu la limite même si c'est pas
nous qui sommes directement
sur ce sujet mais pour nous c'est quand
même un vrai
une vraie difficulté
donc nous nous attendons aussi notre
feuille de route savoir ce qui va être
demandé par rapport au service public de
la petite enfance mais très clairement
enfin pour moi ce qui est important
c'est d'avoir un pilotage
national de la petite enfance
que derrière on puisse être en capacité
de remonter au niveau du ministère ce
qui est fait sur sur le terrain que l'on
puisse
garantir me semble-t-il
quelque chose homogène à la fois pour
pour les familles et l'offre sur sur les
sur les territoires sachant aujourd'hui
nous nous avons des objectifs sur
l'accueil en crèche PSU mais que c'est
ce sont les collectivités qui sont
qui au final vont déterminer s'il
souhaite créer ou pas des déplaces donc
c'est là où je pense que il faut
s'appuyer sur deux outils qui ont été
déployés
sur cette convention d'objectif et de
gestion d'une part le schéma
départemental des services aux familles
et d'autre part les conventions
territoriales globales qui permettent en
fait de faire entre la collectivité qui
porte la CTG et la CAF un bilan
des besoins des des familles et puis
voir finalement sur le territoire
concerné
quelle offre on peut offrir à la fois
sur la petite enfance mais aussi
en France jeunesse tout ce qui concerne
la parentalité l'animation de la vie
sociale mais également le logement et
puis des choses comme l'accès aux droits
ou un certain nombre ça donne une
visibilité plus rien annuelle avec les
financements apportés par la CAF plus
rien nuelle financement à la fois du
National sur fond public et territoire
donc à la main des des cafés mais sur
des lignes nationales et également via
des fonds locaux et donc je pense que
lorsque l'on parle service public de la
petite enfance et bien il faut s'appuyer
sur ces dispositifs qui sont en cours de
déploiement nous avons déjà bien avancé
je pense que en fin d'année
nous serons même au-delà de l'objectif
que on s'était assigné mais il faudra
vraiment compléter et également je me
permets quand même de souligner que il
faut avoir une attention particulière me
semble-t-il sur les outre-mer ou lorsque
au niveau de la métropole nous sommes à
60%
de d'accueil du jeûne enfant nous sommes
plutôt à 17%
sur l'outre-mer donc là aussi c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut avoir en
tête et puis je sais plus l'un d'entre
vous a parlé de l'accès aux droits bien
évidemment c'est un c'est quelque chose
qui est très important pour pour moi
au nom du Conseil d'Administration
puisque nous nous occupons du Front
national d'action sociale ce qui est
important c'est l'accès aux droits et au
service et donc de s'assurer que les
services soient disponibles pour toutes
les familles et sur l'ensemble du
territoire et donc je pense
également au territoire ruraux et pour
ma part j'espère ou j'appelle de mes
vœux que dans la prochaine convention
d'objectifs et de gestion que nous ayons
une ligne sur fond public et territoire
une ligne itinérance pour que on puisse
amener vers les familles un certain
nombre de dispositifs
de services aux familles
et
sur
les assistantes maternelles il y a eu
une réponse effectivement c'est quelque
chose qui remonte et ce qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui
comme pour l'ensemble des autres
salariés il n'existe pas de fonds de
garantie de salaire enfin je me permets
quand même de de le souligner après
c'est pas forcément à la branche famille
de de gérer cela mais c'est quand même
un point qui me semble important à
souligner
lorsque l'on parle de pénurie
aujourd'hui
on remonte beaucoup la pénurie de
professionnels dans la petite enfance
donc comme ça a été dit 10000 places qui
sont créées mais non pourvu je me
permets d'attirer votre attention sur le
fait qu'il manque également de nombreux
professionnels sur l'animation et donc
pour les ALSH ce qui a pour conséquence
sur des colonies de vacances que il y
ait des des
[Musique]
colonies qui étaient
ou des familles avaient déjà
donc fait une réservation et que
finalement ça a été annulé feutre faute
de de personnel nous avons la même chose
sur des ALSH et donc il faut pas
uniquement se focaliser sur la petite
enfance mais également sur sur l'enfance
et
nous avons un vrai sujet d'autant plus
que ça n'a pas enfin les prestations
n'ont pas été revalorisées nous avons
fait un gros effort sur la petite
enfance donc effectivement plus 5%
d'augmentation sur la PSU mais nous
n'avons pas pu faire faute de moyens
la même chose sur des revalorisations
notamment PS à LSH et puis des besoins
aussi sur les centres sociaux
et peut-être je terminerai je puisque
j'ai été interpellée sur le transfert de
la branche famille sur la branche
maladie je pense qu'il y a effectivement
une position philosophique mais vous
avez aussi compris que notre
préoccupation était sur le fait que ça
ne préempte pas la convention
d'objectifs et de gestion
alors même que nous ne sommes qu'au
prémices en fait des des discussions et
nous craignons en fait que ce qui va
rester en fait soit affecté sur la
petite enfance ce qui est une bonne
chose sauf que vraiment enfin la
conciliation vie familiale vie
profession personnel c'est la petite
enfance mais aussi
l'enfant et la jeunesse voilà ce que
sans oublier les autres piliers et bien
évidemment parentalité et animations de
la vie sociale voilà ce que je suis
une question
merci simplement justement sur l'accès
aux droits éventuellement l'accès à la
source et les difficultés que vous
rencontriez pour les APL avec le
glissement le calcul par l'USAP 2%
d'erreurs c'est quand même important
avec des indus et on met les gens en
difficulté plutôt que de leur rendre
service est-ce que ça avançait les
discussions pour avoir justement un
calcul avec des mailles individuelles
plutôt que des mailles agrégées en ce
qui concerne les données et le
rapprochement avec l'argile Carco qui
est bien spécialisée dans dans ce
domaine là pour éviter justement un
pourcentage aussi important dans le
calcul des APL
n'est pas aussi spécialiste que vous du
sujet on s'adosse désormais pour les
aides au logement sur la connaissance
des ressources qu'on a via le système
déclaratif et la DSN grandissent les
employeurs et donc c'est un plus en
termes de contemporalité des ressources
et de fraîcheur des ressources puisque
précédemment sur les appels on prenait
deux ans avant les ressources fiscales
donc il y a un avantage à ça il y a une
difficulté qui effectivement la
fraîcheur des ressources seront mises
avec un parfois un certain nombre
d'incertitudes d'erreurs de
régularisation qui qui crée un petit peu
d'instabilité dans le dans le système ce
qui est certain c'est que on a comme
elle était le premier à passer avec le
dispositif des RM sur un mode industriel
on a été le premier à constater cette
instabilité un peu plus forte et donc à
plaider pour une gouvernance de la
donnée plus plus structurée vous allez
peut-être discuté tout à l'heure avec le
collègue de l'URSSAF caisse nationale
[Musique]
ressources et donc on a potentiellement
des améliorations donc on attend de ça
mais par contre comme le disait madame
San Cerny une grande sensibilité de ses
prestations une grande fragilité des
familles qui sont concernées et donc un
besoin d'avoir un bon conciliation entre
le niveau de fraîcheur et de proximité
des ressources connues qui est
intéressant et le niveau de stabilité
nécessaire pour pas générer à l'inverse
des adultes liés à une trop grande
fraîcheur et à des erreurs ou des
régularisations pas encore effectuées
donc c'est tout le travail en cours sur
ces prestations là et je pense que ce
travail va nous aider dans le sens où
quand on arrive à approche plus globale
y compris sur RSA prime d'activité de
ces sujets on aura une pression globale
sur la qualité de la ressource et la
qualité de la donnée qui sera encore
plus forte que sur le seul aide au
logement pour nous aider à avoir la
qualité la plus forte et la plus
parfaite j'allais dire la perfection est
pas de seconde mais enfin la plus proche
de de la qualité optimale là-dessus il
faut quand même voir que ces outils nous
apporteront des informations
qu'aujourd'hui on peine à avoir on
vérifie on a des moyens importants de
vérification on a des erreurs très
importante des allocataires on peut pas
leur en vouloir vu la complexité du
dispositif et de ce que leur demande en
termes d'expertise de déclaration et du
coup un système très lourd à Dieu et de
rappel qui génère aussi en termes de en
termes de qualité de la relation avec le
public est quand même pas optimale donc
je pense qu'on a une marge
d'amélioration là-dessus qui est quand
même très intéressante et qui sera une
brique parmi d'autres de la solidarité à
la source qui était qui était posée
à propos de la déconjugaison de la hache
vous avez parlé effectivement bas du
traitement de des perdants mais je
voulais savoir si ce traitement des
perdants c'était simplement les perdants
du stock je serai tenté de dire entre
guillemets ou si justement les
situations que ça relève de
l'application en l'état de
la loi font en flux des des perdants que
vous allez essayer en quelque sorte de
d'élargir la loi pour que dans le flux
même enfin si vous comprenez ce que je
veux dire
c'est perdant ne soit pas perdant les
futurs par exemple par contre vous
prêtez des pouvoirs très importants si
vous perdez le pouvoir d'élargir la loi
je crois que ça soit plutôt votre rôle
que le mien
[Musique]
les sujets de réforme c'est celui qui
est obtenu actuellement dans la dans la
prestation c'est pas des situations qui
se poseraient dans 5 ans ou dans 10 ans
non enfin pour le coup enfin votre
question et revient est-ce qu'il faut
des conjuguer là le choix était fait
décongeler donc c'est sûr qu'il y a un
choix transitoire gestion transitoire de
la situation transitoire des gens qui
sont dans le stock pour reprendre ce
terme un peu un peu technocratique
c'est pas exclu par contre quand on aura
des conjugué à la hache on aura des
conjugué les h c'est un choix qui a été
fait et du coup on peut
voilà et notre notre en tout cas notre
requête en tant que gestionnaire de tout
ça c'est qu'on n'est pas à gérer
éternellement deux systèmes parallèles
de nage maintenu pour une partie des
perdant et ça va durer un certain temps
mais c'est vraiment pour le stock et que
ce stock inévitablement va diminuer
progressivement en fonction des
évolutions de situation des sorties etc
et qu'à un moment donné on fermera le
stock de perdant et on va pas
réalimenter un stock de et on sera sur
le nouveau dispositif c'est un choix qui
a été fait il faut voilà exactement
c'est un dispositif forcément
transistors oui je sais je sais je sais
mais après je vais encore une fois c'est
vous qui faites la loi donc
merci beaucoup
coucou madame la Présidente et Monsieur
le Directeur